sollte es zum gas notfall kommen also
der dritten und letzten stufe des
notfallplans sollen nach derzeitigem
stand privater haushalte bis zuletzt
versorgt werden und damit länger als die
industrie
wirtschaftsmanager hatten zuletzt auf
die große wichtigkeit der industrie
hingewiesen und eine änderung der
reihenfolge gefordert dagegen
protestiert wiederum unter anderem die
verbraucherzentrale bundesverband im
fall von versorgungsengpässen müssen
private haushalte als sogenannte
geschützte kunden weiter mit erdgas und
anderen energien sicher versorgt werden
die diskussion dürfte weitergehen
industrie und haushalte sind mit 36,9
und 30,8 prozent jedenfalls die beiden
größten gasverbraucher und somit größten
konkurrenten um den eventuell zu knapp
werdenden rohstoff
zu gunsten der haushalte forderten die
chefs der gewerkschaften verdi und die
ig metall jetzt zudem eine deckelung der
energie- und gaspreise
und laut einer berechnung des
forschungszentrums jülich müsste die
industrie im extremfall wochenlang auf
gas verzichten aus allen richtungen
kommt die forderung sparen beim
energieverbrauch ziemlich sicher scheint
der gas notfall würde ein weitreichender
notfall und eine ebensolche
herausforderung für wirtschaftsminister
habeck und verbraucherschutz ministerin
lemke
genau über dieses thema spreche ich
jetzt mit der
bundesverbraucherschutzministerin steffi
lemke von den grünen schönen guten
morgen schönen guten morgen frau meiner
nach dem aktuell notfallplan gas muss im
fall der fälle zuerst die industrie auf
gas verzichten das haben wir gehört
daran gibt es aber kritik vor allem von
seiten der industrie inwieweit wird man
denn da noch einmal nachjustieren von
ihrer seite ich finde erst mal wichtig
zu betonen dass die gasversorgung die
energieversorgung gegenwärtiger sicher
ist das heißt wir würden hier über einen
wirklichen notfall sprechen den
versuchen wir innerhalb der
bundesregierung gemeinsam zu vermeiden
das heißt vor allem das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium arbeitet
daran ersatzmöglichkeiten zu finden und
sollte dieser notfall tatsächlich
eintreten wie gesagt es gilt ihn zu
vermeiden
dann wären in der tat infrastrukturen
wie zum beispiel weil wie zum beispiel
krankenhäuser aber eben auch die
privaten verbraucherinnen diejenigen die
tatsächlich abgesichert sein müssen und
dazu steht die bundesregierung auch
jetzt so argumentiert natürlich die
industrie trotzdem naja wenn sie zuerst
abgeklemmt würden dann gäbe es demnächst
massenarbeitslosigkeit
damit wäre im grunde verbraucherinnen
und verbrauchern auch nicht geholfen
noch einmal ist mir wichtig zu betonen
dass wir über ein szenario reden an dem
wir im moment alle arbeiten dass es
nicht einschritt das bleibt vor der
klammer stehen und wir können jetzt alle
einen beitrag dazu leisten eben auch in
der wirtschaft in den privaten
haushalten energie zu sparen dafür gibt
es verschiedene möglichkeiten
die
verbraucherschutzzentralen das
bundesumweltamt das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium weisen auf
verschiedene möglichkeiten hin und für
dieses wirkliche krisenszenario wir
sprechen hier über eine tatsächliche
krise die dann eingetreten wäre wird
viele probleme mit sich bringen und dass
wir in einer solchen situation
krankenhäuser private verbraucher
besonders schützen müssen ich glaube das
sollte konsens in unserer gesellschaft
sein bundeswirtschaftsminister harbeck
hatte am wochenende betont dass
deutschland beim öl mittlerweile ein
ganzes stück weniger abhängig ist aber
das ebenso ein geplanter importstopp des
kommen könnte eben doch bedeuten würde
das öl dann doch noch immer teurer wird
wie können sie da als
verbraucherschutzministerin vielleicht
noch mal gegen steuern oder muss da noch
mal gegengesteuert werden die
bundesregierung hat in der vergangenen
woche ja das zweite entlastungs paket
verabschiedet mit dem wir gegen die
gegenwärtige preisentwicklung schon
gegensteuern das wird für die nächsten
drei monate eine entlastung bringen die
frage wie sich die preise insgesamt auf
den globalen märkten unter
lieferengpässen in china durch wetter
extreme durch die vor allem natürlich
rohstoffmärkte die durch den krieg jetzt
auf allen ebenen unter druck komme sei
das bei öl gas auch bei den
lebensmitteln wie wir darauf weiter
reagieren werden wir schrittweise immer
wieder bewerten und entscheiden müssen
gegenwärtig werden wir uns die wirkung
des ersten und des zweiten
entlastungspaket wo es ja verschiedene
entlastungen gibt sowohl für die
steuerzahler direkt aber eben auch bei
den öffentlichen nahverkehrsmitteln bei
den energiepreisen direkt diese wirkung
werden wir jetzt bewerten und falls
weitere maßnahmen notwendig sein werden
dann wird die bundesregierung auch diese
ergreifen viele von diesen maßnahmen die
kommen ja jetzt erst zum beispiel das
neuen euro ticket was sie angesprochen
haben wie können sie denn eigentlich
sicherstellen dass diese ganzen
entlastungen die sie beschlossen haben
und auf den weg gebracht haben auch
tatsächlich beim verbraucher ankommen
wer beim neuen euro ticket ist das ja
jetzt geklärt der bundesverkehrsminister
hat es mit den bundesmitteln
landesverkehrsminister auf den weg
gebracht dieses neuen euro ticket kann
jetzt wirken bei der frage der
entlastung der steuerzahler geht es über
eine pauschale pro steuerzahler bei den
hartz iv regelsätzen geht es über die
normalen hartz-iv-regelsätze und zum
beispiel bei der absenkung der eeg
umlage habe ich ja mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsministerium gemeinsam
die regelung getroffen dass tatsächlich
gesetzlich sichergestellt wird dass
diese eeg-umlage bei den
verbraucherinnen ankommt deshalb wird
das im energiewirtschaftsgesetz klar
geregelt wir haben dort auch weitere
möglichkeiten für besseren
verbraucherschutz geschah in dem jetzt
nicht mehr einfach gekündigt werden kann
wir hatten dort ja zum jahreswechsel bei
den strom billig anbietern eine
kündigungswelle die noch gar nichts mit
dem krieg zu tun hatte sondern einfach
nur mit preisspekulationen und auch dort
haben wir jetzt einen riegel
vorgeschoben um die verbraucher besser
zu schützen haben sie also einiges auf
den weg gebracht eine sache die immer
noch angesprochen wird als mögliche
entlastung ist das zum beispiel
nachbarländer wie belgien die
atomkraftwerke länger laufen lassen
warum ist das für deutschland keine
option wenn wir uns die den beitrag die
deutschen akw s zur stromversorgung hier
liefern anschauen es ist ein relativ
geringer natürlich kann man darüber
diskutieren dass gegenwehr durch jede
kilowattstunde zählt aber die betreiber
der akw s haben sehr deutlich gemacht
dass sie für den fall der weiter
verlängerung von laufzeiten
das gesamte risiko sowohl das
finanzielle das versicherungstechnische
auf den staat übertragen würden und ich
bin der meinung dass wir wirklich
bessere möglichkeiten haben das
wirtschaftsministerium und ich arbeiten
gegenwärtig daran den ausbau der
erneuerbaren vor allem photovoltaik und
wind natürlich an allererster stelle
voranzutreiben das geht schneller das
geht preiswerter als akw s neu zu bauen
und vor allem die situation in
frankreich wo viele akw es gegenwärtig
abgeschaltet sind aus sicherheitsgründen
und wir strom nach frankreich
exportieren dort die strompreise an
vielen vielen tagen deutlich höher
liegen an den börsen als in deutschland
zeigt dass wir mit den erneuerbaren den
richtigen weg gehen und den sollten wir
mit wirklich voller energie sagt die
verbraucherschutz und umweltministerin
steffi lemke von den grünen vielen dank
fürs gespräch vielen dank